pop
[Musique]
non
charlie aux enfants ne sont pas là mais
votre grand mère j'ai réussi à la
complète
[Applaudissements]
bon
c'était mes voisins se voir accusé levez
vous payez décliner vos noms prénoms
date et lieu de naissance
il parlait un peu plus fort s'il vous
plaît baron charline marine et le 14
novembre 1944 à ouville le haut à fait
sûrs et domicile ouvrière j'habitais
ferme des chaumes à ouville prénom du
père charles nous et prénom de votre
mère marguerite merci pouvez vous
asseoir s'est greffé monsieur le
greffier veillée je vous prie effectue
l'appel des jurés qui répondront
présents à dénoncer de brno monsieur
robert madame 9 et riant l'âme la feria
monsieur gruel
madame haman monsieur michaud aimera ou
monsieur rendra des monsieur madame
pourquoi puisque touche
le frange rays jury la cour de recevoir
votre serment vous jurer et prom était
d'examiner avec l'attention la plus
scrupuleuse des charges qui seront
portées contre par an charline de notre
ayant mené les intérêts de l'accusé ni
ceux de la société qui l'accusent de ne
communiquer avec personne jusqu après
votre déclaration de n'écouter ni la
haine la méchanceté ni la crainte ou
l'affection de vous décider d'après les
charges et les moyens de défense suivant
votre conscience et votre intime
conviction avec l'impartialité la
fermeté qui contiennent un homme probe
et libre et de conserver le secret des
délibérations même après la cessation de
vos fonctions
madame aux lèvres olemps mademoiselle
thérèse delvar monsieur lucien appert le
jure monsieur frédéric dupré l'usure
monsieur maurice dionne monsieur madame
nicole pour toi françoise raul monsieur
eugène gruel fait le jeu et monsieur
bernard aubert là je déclare le jury
définitivement constitué vous pouvez
vous asseoir
celui-ci appelait je vous prie les
témoins cités
alors monsieur quentin michel va
monsieur ferrand et les madmoizelles
vers mon petit monsieur millau paul
payan monsieur monsieur dumont excuses
aux victimes chez le président voici le
savent qu'à médical battait d'inventaire
attestant qu'il va affecter la garder le
lit une semaine bruno drye laxisme et du
corps médical décidément moi aussi j'ai
la grippe l'otan celui-là il ne devait
pas être entendu sur les faits c'est
moins grave vient nous passerons donc
outre à la carence du c'ur du monde
objection être coûté poursuivi l'appel
lemonnier mais m côté conduisait s'il
vous plaît les témoins dans la chambre
qui leur est réservé ils resteront
jusqu'à leur déposition
merci
que je vous invite à écouter
attentivement la règle qui vous renvoie
devant cette cour d'assises sur les
greffiers veillées ont donné lecture à
haute et intelligible voix
le 24 novembre 1978 à 18h24 alertés par
la sueur ferrand emile gardien de nuit à
l'usiné la jolie mal c'est alexis les
looks et seine maritime l'adjudant
commandant la brigade de gendarmerie de
nexi seront des trains garbé de ladite
usine il et découvraient le corps
inanimé du sieur entraygues charles
ouvriers de la ville solibail est blessé
à la tête et au corps parle instrument
contondant devait décéder durant son
transfert à l'hôpital
l'inculpé mademoiselle baron charline
ouvrière à la jolie my présent sur les
lieux
interrogés avouent avoir mon
mortellement frappée d'une barre de fer
le sieur entraygues charles après qu'ils
aient eu un rapport sexuel la cour à
prendre à délibérer dico des pièces une
astuce ou résulte de charges suffisantes
contre par charline d'avoir un excellent
et louviers le 24 novembre 1978 en tout
cas de leur sens de la cour d'assises
est rapide en ont prescrit dans les
volontaires mon amour en très grand
charles
un préfet réprimé par l'article 220 15
et 3 104 du code pénal prononce la mise
en accusation de baron charline et la
renvoie devant la meute devant la cour
d'assises pour y être jugé j'ai vu
j'ai vaincu la salle vous croyez vous
non je te dirais pas ça ça se reproduit
je prononce le huis clos bien accuser
devez-vous vous avez été placé sous
mandat de dépôt le 24 novembre 1978 puis
cette date vous subissez le régime de la
détention provisoire
célibataire vous avez deux enfants
comparaissait devant cette cour pour
homicide volontaire
les immigrants passible de la réclusion
criminelle à perpétuité
vous interrogeait d'abord sur votre vie
jusqu'aux faits qui vous sont imputés
puis sur ces faits eux mêmes et vous
pourrez vous exprimer librement pendant
les débats est-ce bien clair pour dire
oui monsieur le président passons bien
vous est né le 18 novembre 1944 à
ouville l'eau dans la ferme des chaumes
qui exploitait vos grands parents
sébastien et mars et l'urée votre mère
leur fille unique marguerite marie avait
alors 16 ans notre père charles baron
apprenti maçon en avait 20 ans et est
embauché l'année précédente aux chaumes
pour échapper au st lô une idée il
s'était nouée c'était pas du tout le
monde dit on a été très pieuse et très
naïve baron en a profité c'est votre
père que vous appelez baron j'ai
toujours appelé comme ça
enfin toujours est il que votre grand
mère déçu reproche à ce garçon qui
découvre que votre mère est enceinte et
le somment de réparer comme on dit il
s'y résout en ou 44 3 mois avant votre
naissance à ce que le grand mère l'avait
menacé des gendarmes
il avait préféré le mariage à la prison
vous ne se trouvait pas de rappeler à
maman devant nous et devant tout le
monde quand il avait bu mais ce mariage
ne sera pas des plus
effet le jeune couple va s'installer à
louviers et une vie assez misérablement
votre mais revient à coucher aux chaumes
puis en décembre retourne auprès de son
mari en vous abandonnera pas abandonné
elle venait me voir tous les dimanches
je regrette que vous contredire mais
d'après madame sûrs et vos parents
cessent définitivement leur visite le
jour de votre troisième anniversaire on
vous êtes passé six ans chez votre grand
mère
oui mais ce n'était pas la faute de
moment est venu de faire une fausse
couche grand-mère a reproché sa à
barreaux il lui a dit de ne plus
remettre les pieds à la ferme alors lui
il a défendu à maman de venir sans lui
qui vous l'a dit votre mère était bien
jeune c'est très peu je me souviens très
bien
elle pleurait s'il avait pu m'amener je
suis sûr qu'elle aurait fait d'ailleurs
dès qu'elle a pu les mêmes chercher mais
c'est exact en mars 50 quand votre père
trouve un emploi ou grands chantiers des
vosges dans la proche banlieue d'epinal
métal vous met alors à l'école chez les
soeurs de la visitation
vous étiez je cite une gentille enfants
soumise mais peu sociable vous fuyez
paraît-il les autres enfants l'avait
l'accent normand ça les faisait rire
bien
votre soeur madeleine née en janvier 51
de mes jeux je cite encore une petite
rebelle qui n'avoue jamais ses erreurs
il faut dire que le climat familial
s'est considérablement détérioré la
santé de votre mère s'est altérée
l'humeur de votre père également se
chamaillent beaucoup mais on se
réconcilie pourtant sur l'oreiller comme
audi puisque entre 51 et 53 votre âme
votre mère en rade nouvelle grossesse
qu'elle ne peut mener à terme n'avait
pas retomber en simple docteur l'avait
dit à barreaux
elle a failli mourir la deuxième fois
mais lui c'était brut
en plus si les cogner dessus et vous
vous voisins ne signale pas de violence
physique pensée m'a jamais donc en tout
cas c'est tout donc quand ils ramenaient
chez nous des filles qui draguait au
bistrot alors faisais ma maman j'ai
personnes pourtant le 2 mai 1954 vous
vous précipitez en pleine nuit à la
gendarmerie
que s'était il passé cette nuit là mais
je sais mais j'aimerais que le répéter à
la cour il faut
eh bien je dormais dans leur chambre
avec madeleine
et puis j'ai entendu un grand bruit
moment criait ça m'a réveillée j'ai
allumé
elle était par terre à côté du lit avec
sa chemise de nuit te déchirer car
ramener sur elles
lui il était à genoux sur elle son
pantalon même pas déshabiller il eût
écarté les poignées l'injuriait comme un
fou elle pleurait j'ai voulu les séparer
il s'est redressé il nous a traînés dans
l'autre pièce madeleine et moi il a
claqué la porte j'ai cru qu'il devenait
fou alors j'ai couru chez les gendarmes
pour qu'ils viennent tout de suite ça
les a fait rire est tout de même deux
qui m'ont amené je crois que baroin a eu
peur il a pu toucher après ça quelques
mois plus tard le 15 juillet 1954 votre
père abandonne le domicile conjugal n'y
reviendra plus que par intermittence
jusqu'en novembre 1960 date à laquelle
il quitte la france pour une destination
inconnue en compagnie de la femme avec
qui il vivait n'avait jamais plus de ses
nouvelles
vous entrez le 1er décembre 60 à textile
unis une importante filature d'epinal
comme apprenti au dfe train débourrage
monsieur président les bourrages c'est
exactement donnez moi
ensuite vous allez brûler les étapes
puisque vous vous retrouvez coupeuse en
février soit en de 63 c'est à dire si je
ne m'abuse
vous voyez un qualifié au genre et enfin
votre votre vie professionnelle est
satisfaisante
et là c'est votre mère meurt le 2 juin
63 à la suite d'une longue et
douloureuse maladie
votre grand mère propose alors de vous
recueillir à ouville votre sueur et vous
votre soeur accepte vous refuser parce
que vous avez rencontré henri dumont non
henry ne m'intéresse pas plus qu'un
autre à ce moment là j'étais coupeuse à
textile unis ça me plaise voilà enfin
vous désirez contraire il ya des noms
j'ai dit que j'étais sous payés c'est
pas la même chose
enfin cette façon dumont vous intéresser
tout de même un petit peu quand vous
aménager avec lui cette cité des
abeilles le premier aujourd'hui 64 nous
c'était un amas de lusine c'est tout on
s'entendait bien
mais le loyer était trop cher pour moi
tout seul alors j'en ai parlé à henry
qui vivaient à l'hôtel et on a décidé
d'habiter ensemble qu'après quand je les
mieux connus c'est une autre chose mais
six mois avant nous avons compris donc
en décembre 64 vous donner le jour à une
petite marie l'année suivante en
décembre également un petit serge sans
que ces heureux événements accidentels
peut-être qu'il n'est pas venu
jamais j'aurais fait ça à mes gosses je
les ai voulu tous les deux si proche
mais monsieur le président pourquoi
enfin ça ne vous incite pas à
régulariser votre union malgré les
instances de votre grand-mère où vivait
aussi bien comme ça arrive moi mais
j'entends bien m'enfin dans dans
l'intérêt de vos enfants
enfin je dois dire que votre concubin je
résume ses propos louve ouvert que deux
mères de famille la bonne entente qui
règne dans votre ménage ou manet
heureusement de front vos tâches
ménagères et autres activités
professionnelles
tout va donc pour le mieux jusqu'en
septembre 67 lorsque georges leroux est
nommé à la maîtrise de votre atelier de
coupe ville et des milliers de l'accusé
avec ce georges leroux d'en avoir une
incidence directe sur les faits qui
l'amène devant cette cour le roux n'a
pas plutôt pris ses fonctions que vous
demandez à changer d'atelier pour
convenance personnelle
connaissiez-vous avant septembre 67 un
peu j'étais sorti une fois ou deux avec
lui comme au mans était à l'hôpital
puis il est devenu un petit chef plus
fréquentés terme avec lui je savais que
c'était un chef infecte vous savez tout
monsieur le président vous entendiez au
juste par le chef infecte très injuste
forcé les cadences pour faire sauter
nous heures supplémentaires et puis il
était grossier il draguait tout les
jeunes de son atelier et celles qui ne
voulaient pas y trouver un motif pour
les faire envoyer
enfin pourquoi ne pas vous plaindre
auprès de votre comité d'entreprise ou
de la direction plutôt d'invoquer des
des convenances personnelles
j'avais pas de me retrouver chômeuse on
n'était pas très solidaire dans ce temps
là c'est en 68 seulement que nous avons
compris si vous avez compris on se veut
centrer tout ça est injuste
il avoue profiter en effet des
événements de mai 68 et des grève pour
exiger parmi d'autres revendications
le renvoi pur et simple de le roux pour
abus de pouvoir la direction accepte
seulement de le déplacer ou thyssen et
surtout s est engagé à le flanquer
dehors s'il manquait de respect aux
ouvrières bien bien deux ans plus tard
en mars 79 7 mars et vous payez votre
section syndicale d'exiger à nouveau son
renvoi alors commencé à embêter les
filles du tissage comme ils nous avaient
embêter nous avant 68 c'était un cas de
renvoi la direction avait promis elle
devait tenir parole c'est ce que j'ai
dit à la section c'est ce que je voulais
dire à l'assemblée générale
c'est pour m'empêcher de le dire que le
roux est venu chez moi enfin ça c'est
votre version des faits nous pourrons
hélas entendre celle de l'euro décédé en
décembre eu 76 d'une embolie enfin une
chose est sûre le 7 mars à 22h le roux
seul chez vous votre concubin qui
travaille de nuit à textile unis est
absent vos enfants dorment et c'est une
heure bien tardive pour recevoir un
homme infecte comme vous dites
d'après vous il vous demande de ne pas
parler de lui à cette assemblée générale
vous avez
faisait et tenté de le pousser vers la
porte lors il aurait il aurait abusé de
vous sans que vos voisins qui ont
entendu sonner et reçoivent le moindre
bruit semble vous songez à crier à les
appeler vous maintenez cette version les
enfants étaient à côté je voulais pas
qu'ils se réveillent vois ça admettons
le roux s'en va votre concubin revient à
minuit vous nous dites rien de ce qui
s'est passé pourquoi ça ne regardait pas
ah bon c'est à dire des bancs
il serait allé passer à la figure à
l'heure où il aurait eu des ennuis ça
aurait changé quoi ça m'était arrivé à
moi pas bien c'est une façon de
présenter les choses
enfin le lendemain vous retourner à
l'usiné ne parlait de rien à vos caméras
de travail ni à votre syndicat pourquoi
croire mais moi je veux bien vous croire
seulement comment se fait-il alors que
vers 16 heures comme ça parce que quand
vous quittez lusine vous vous rendez au
commissariat des abeilles ils vont
porter plainte contre leur ou alors le
matin vous pouvez papy l'après midi vous
pouvez à ce que le viol c'est un crime
n'avait pas le droit de me taire la
vente elle devait être pour lui aussi
pour qu'il s'en aille pour qu'il fasse
plus de mal à personne
il m'a fait et deux jours plus tard le
le le 10 mars vous retirer cette plainte
pas très cohérent tout ça non c'est pas
très cohérent j'avais plus jeunes
étaient tous dit que j'étais une idiote
rumeurs qui qui vous a dégoté une idiote
inspecteurs mes camarades henry il
disait que je cherchais des ennuis que
ce serait mieux pour tout le monde si je
retirerai ma plainte j'ai craqué je les
fais les ennuis j'ai eu quand même je
licencieux en effet une malpropre après
dix ans sans indemnités sans préavis
sans rien donner un look et je cite
faute professionnelle le graves et
réitérées absences injustifiées
ma seule faute professionnelle en disant
c'est d'avoir voulu faire tenir sa
promesse à la direction
ça m'a suivi partout je pointer au
chômage pendant deux mois sans rien
trouver
ils étaient publics l'industrie textile
traversait traversait une période de
crise en 77 où j'étais sur la liste
noire textile unis me l'ont dit à
l'agencé de l'emploi
la fosse violée à la fin j'aurais pu
présenter nulle part tant j'avais honte
d'entendre eric ané derrière mon dos je
vous ai même plus sortir de chez moi
c'est pour ça que je suis parti avec mes
enfants pour qu'ils aient pas honte
votre concubin ne vous a pas retenu il
avait honte de moi lui aussi jamais
chercheurs joue au revoir ses enfants et
pas de raison c'était les miens pas les
siens thomas pas le sien il n'avait pas
reconnu
ah oui pourquoi pas ce que je voulais
pas et j'ai eu bien raison
sans ça le premier en 1970 vous quittez
sans espoir de retour epinal où vous
aviez vécu 20 ans vous vous réfugiez
auchan de chez votre grand-mère
d'aborder cette partie de votre vie
quelqu'un peut-il poser des questions
sur l'avocat général merci monsieur le
président a accusé selon vous votre père
charles baron était une brute mais je
cite la soeur supérieure de votre
couvent en 1954 madame baron nada baron
votre maman lamarre on m'a confié
plusieurs fois que l'hostilité de
charline en versant terre la penne et
j'ai réprimandé l'enfance beaucoup parce
que moi je savais que ce n'était pas
juste que je pense à toutes les prières
que j'ai fait pour qu'il la laisse
tranquille mais vous aviez même d'après
la surf et une neuvaine pour ça sarria
changé mais c'est pourquoi le 12 mai
vous allez aller chercher les gendarmes
pour qu'ils appellent le miracle que le
le bon lieu vous refusez il met en état
numérique brut qui venait de violer sa
femme sont déduites une gamine de neuf
ans vous savez très bien de ce que
raconte votre client m bon maintenant
parlons l'euro vous nous avez dit que le
fréquentiez dès 1962 pendant que votre
mère était à l'hôpital
j'étais avec lui au cinéma il faut 2
vous ne vous connaissiez pas mx1 vous
l'avait reçue chez vous le 7 mars 70
comme un vieil ami en tenues d'intérieur
à 10 heures du soir c'est pas très
prudents encore le monsieur cours soit
tellement tu amateurs de jeunes femmes
je pensais que chez moi jusqu'à rien
mais que lui est risqué gros si
l'attaqué nous vrillière non plus l
usine mais chez elle ce n'est pas une
question simplement une hypothèse m mais
le silence de l'accusé met une réponse
tout comme l'absence du concubin qui n'a
pas cru à ce violent c'est pas vrai
l'inspecteur lemonnier ni votre syndicat
personne n'y a cru parce que c'était pas
croyable mais c'est ça c'est pour cela
pour ce mensonge calomnieux que vous
avez quitté epinal c'est pas vrai j'ai
quitté epinal parce que j'avais honte
d'avoir été si bête c'est tout ben voilà
il fallait le dire merci mademoiselle m
pardon de vous poser cette question mais
l'attitude du ministère public nous y
oblige
qu'est ce qui s'est passé exactement
entre le rouet vous de cette mare 70
soir
j'ai voulu le pousser vers la porte il
m'a pris dans ses bras
je me suis débattue ma robe s'est
déchiré
et puis j'étais paralysé les enfants
étaient à côté j'ai revu la chemise de
nuit déchiré la chemise de votre mère
relevé déchiré par le père baron et vos
enfants avec un côté je vais pas qu'ils
voient ça à d'autres questions non
messieurs président bien vous quittez
donc epinal et dès votre arrivée à
ouville 2970 vous vous inscrivez à l'
agence pour l'emploi de louviers entre
le 3 août 70 c'est le 1er octobre 73
vous serez tour à tour contre sur les
décombres de louviers employés au
supermarché de weixin caissière à celui
de quarouble et serge en passant tout
dix emplois enfin aux roses que vous ne
conserveraient jamais plus de deux mois
aux filatures n'embauchent pas beaucoup
et puis je n'avais pas de références
rien vous engage pourtant la jolie main
une petite filature de nexi en octobre
passant très occasionnel pour être tard
la chaîne d'assemblage a vu que je
connais c'est le métier elle a demandé à
me garder
quand vous dites richesse vous entendez
vous entendez bien répondantes règle la
femme de la victime
je précise que la victime charente
règles étaient employés à l'entretien du
matériel laissant beaucoup site où vous
l'ayez prise en grippe
je n'ai pas ses manières site ou via le
menu était grossier avec sa femme ils
appellent la vieille et draguer toutes
les filles de vente elle lui disait rien
bien bref raymond 30 règle ne tarde pas
vous faire ses confidences et vous
prenez publiquement sa défense contre
son mari
longtemps après monsieur le président au
début je me suis tenu tranquille mais
vivent tous les trois qu'il comme vous
dites juste contre 74
voilà ça se gâte un peu parce que en
plus des pays d'oc des prises de bec que
vous avez avait contraint la plupart de
vos collègues masculins vont militer en
faveur de la loi sur l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse ou distribué des
tracts ou créer une sorte de comité de
défense des pats comité on se réunissait
de temps en temps entre femmes pour
céder quand on nous exploite être au
double et je ne vous reproche pas vos
activités
non je constate simplement que votre
cible favori
de champdôtre entraygues millau bien
d'autres tout ce qui nous manquait de
respect enfin surtout charles entraygues
puisqu'en mai 76 vous suggérez à sa
femme de se réfugier chez vous pour se
mettre à l'abri de ces violences à elle
comme à d'autres femmes du groupe a plus
monsieur le président mais enfin vous
revenez tenter si bien à la charge
contre 78 au mois de janvier elle cède à
vos instances et abandonne enfin le
domicile conjugal pour s'installer chez
votre grand mère c'est un peu chez moi
aussi je paye ma part de tous mais je
pars j'ai pas dit non ça se passe et
voyons le 15 janvier c'est ça à ce
moment là dites vous c'est à ce moment
là des vous que vous auriez confiée à
madame entraygues vos mésaventures
d'epinal avec le rouge le 18 janvier
après qu'il ya un chercher sa femme d'un
titre ce jour vous relations avec
raymond d'entraygues ce distantes d'une
année s'écoule ainsi presque
paisiblement et nous en arrivons à la
journée du 24 novembre et aux faits qui
vous sont reprochés
mais avant d aborder les questions il ya
deux matin du 24 novembre charles
entraygues et à réparer une machine dans
l'atelier où vous travaillez selon vos
dires il fait une allusion france en
avouant lui avec le roux à epinal en 70
vous demander de lui parler en
particulier il accepte
vous prenez rendez vous le soir même
dans le hangar b de l'usiné dans les
hangars mais sur président je devais me
retrouver devant le hangar à la sortie
des ateliers
on a parlé un peu puis la pluie a
commencé alors on y rentre et s'abriter
mais ça c'est un point quelque peu
controversé mais nous verrons que
s'est-il passé ensuite
suite je lui ai dit que j'étais ni
menteuse ni hypocrite je lui ai dit que
j'étais nu une menteuse une hypocrite
que j'avais réellement été violée par un
petit chef que j'avais peur peur de tout
le monde que je supportais
aucun homme ne touche que j'aimerais
mieux mourir ça la fait rire
il m'a bousculé il a déchiré maromme et
lors des deux roues il vous aurait violé
son que vous défendiez je pouvais pas
bouger je pouvais pas crier c'était
comme dans un cauchemar je ne savais
plus puis je les ai vus se relever il
m'a regardé la rue il m'a dit tu vois
que c'est pas la mort à vous que je t'ai
bien du service et ils riaient
je voulais qu'ils arrêtent de rire j'ai
senti un morceau de fer sous ma main
droite j'ai frappé une fois après je ne
me rappelle plus jusqu'au moment où
ferrand est entré vous vous souvenez que
dupont duke ou bien les questions m si
mal et il va encore mettre au bio dieu
mais j'ai bien demandé à l'accusé
pourquoi elle met une telle constance a
invité en tête à tête des hommes affecte
chaque fois qu'il veut s'en débarrasser
pourquoi n'avez-vous pas donné
rendez-vous à entraigues dans un café on
aurait pu nous entendre je ne voulais
pas mais voulait pas qu'on rapporte à
madame entre avec votre petit rendez
vous répondez n'existait plus rouge
je croyais que je le trouve un crémieux
santé - jolie formule bon voilà on vous
dit qu'il voulait viol sans que vous
puissiez résister bien que cette fois
vos enfants ne soient pas dans la pièce
voisine pour moi je veux bien mais face
à cette barre de fer que vous avez senti
sous votre main après vous ne l'aviez
pas senti avant je l'avais pas remarqué
sans ça
sans ça vous auriez frappé avant et vous
pour une fois je suis d'accord avec vous
je n'ai je ne sais pas non plus vous
pouvez vous asseoir
nous allons procéder à l'audition des
experts d'être écoutés a ajouté le
docteur de pour s'y amuser le docteur de
courcy s'il vous plaît bonjour fondateur
bernard de courcy psychiatre inscrit sur
la liste des experts agréés près les
tribunaux magistrat instructeur vous a
donné mission d'examiner l'accusé sur le
plan psychiatrique et médico
psychologique amp au panier de ma
consoeur la docteure n'entraîne nikon
qui ne sont font bien j'aurai d'apporter
votre concours et la justice en votre
honneur à votre conscience
je jure capteurs ne vous écoutent où
nous avons eu plusieurs entretiens avec
charline baron sans jamais parvenir à
établir avec quel un contact réel
l'intelligence est d'un bon niveau la
mémoire excellente mais sélective
le jugement est souvent faussée par
l'émotivité et le sujet reconnaît
difficilement ses erreurs sur le plan
affectif
elle est bloquée et ne plus fonctionner
qu'à travers des concepts moraux la
dignité la justice
on note une tendance à toujours sur
expliquer tout ça constitue une
personnalité d'emprunt ou si vous
préférez une personnalité irréel de d'y
hâter leur est tout le temps un
personnage non je dirais plutôt qu'à un
moment de sa vie il lui a fallu inventer
à un système de défense pour fuir une
culpabilité est écrasante et qu'elle est
maintenant prisonnière de ce système
qu'est ce que tu reproches docteur roux
le crime d'être né on le lui a reproché
dès sa petite enfance sa mère a commis
un péché en aimant son père et charline
est l'incarnation de ce péché de 7 août
il lui paraît donc évident que sa mère
ne peut pas l'aimer
pas vrai messie et pire encore la mère
épouse le père pour racheter cette honte
mais c'est un mariage malheureux
charline est donc doublement coupable il
lui faut donc nier cette réalité en la
remplaçant par une autre où elle
charline serait innocente
dès lors pour elle la mère n'est pas
coupable
c'est le père qu'il faut détruire il
faut détruire pour mériter l'amour de la
mère à qui il faut aussi rendre sa
dignité
charline a besoin d'un modèle de père et
de mère pour s'accepter comme être
humain et comme femme sinon elle n'est
ni l'un ni l'autre mais un autre un
enjeu justicier oui et cela entraîne
toutes sortes de conduite névrotique
sexualité perturbé combat contre le
pouvoir viril militantisme féminisme un
comportement de panique
en face de toute tentative de séduction
brutale qui lui rappelle la séduction de
sa mère c'est à dire la honte dans ce
cas son système de défense est détruit
et dans un état de détresse extrême elle
peut tuer pourtant cet état ne relève en
fait d'aucune anomalie mentale ou
psychique et donc accessible à une
sanction pénale
oui merci docteur questions du président
comprend bien d'acteurs
l'accusé est un menu bio nan non elle ne
fume jamais une contre vérité
mais entre deux interprétations
possibles elle choisira celle qui la
disculpe à ses yeux - de chicanes ont
pas l arrange un peu la réalité
orgueil la la sexualité perturbé et ça
veut dire quoi
inhibée pudeur extrême peu de besoins
sexuels à cause de ce premier viol qui
l'obsède oui mais si vous voulez me
faire dire que charline baron cherchait
à se faire violer pour satisfaire sa
sexualité non elle n'est aucunement
perverse besoin
extrêmement pudique au parlement elle se
prend pour un ange mercie d'auteur vous
avez parlé de sexualité perturbé mais ma
cliente a vécu maritalement pendant six
ans avec le même homme dont elle a une
volontairement deux enfants oui elle a
fait le contraire de ce qu'a fait sa
mère en choisissant son partenaire en
ayant volontairement deux enfants qui
porterait son nom à elle et on les
enveloppant d'un amour maternel
hypertrophié cétacés névrotique ça aussi
notre merci d'athènes eu la courbe merci
docteur premier témoin s'il vous plaît
nous aurions dû entendre auparavant le
professeur le dain qui a précédé a
procédé à l'examen médico légal
il fait hélas aujourd'hui une
communication au congrès international
de zurich
mais nous avons son rappeur si besoin en
était à défaut de sa présence physique
nous pouvons donc passé outre
quels sont vos nom prénom âge profession
et domicile
quentin michel 49 ans adjudant de
gendarmerie comment la brigade de lexie
jeu de parler sans rien et ce en train
de dire toute la vérité rien que la
vérité levé la main droite et dit usure
jupe n'accourent écoute votre déposition
j'ai été saisi de la sphère le 24
novembre 1978 24 par appel téléphonique
de ferran le gardien de nuit de la jolie
marie je me suis immédiatement rendu sur
les lieux avec deux gendarmes
nous sommes arrivés en même temps que
l'ambulance et gérant nous attendaient
devant la porte grande ouverte du hangar
b il tenait un revolver et le braquet
vers l'intérieur du hangar à deux mètres
environ le creux qui y figurent un homme
était recroquevillé sur le sol
continuent à un mètre environ
je visais une barre de fer que j'allais
faire saisir comme pièces à conviction
même se soucier veillée faire identifier
la pièce à conviction s'il vous plaît
poursuivez ferrand m'a alors désigner
une femme accroupie dans le fond du
hangar et il m'a dit qu'est ce que vous
attendez pour l'arrêter comme elle
soutenait prostré dans son coin
j'ai d'abord fait photographier le corps
d'entraygues dont le pouls battait
encore fait globablement avant
d'autoriser les ambulanciers à le
déplacer
j'ai alors constaté que la braguette
était ouverte avec un pan de chemise qui
dépassait et qui était toute humide du
sang de liqueur signal comme l'analyse
ultérieure doivent être révélées je me
suis alors dirigées vers la femme et
j'ai reconnu charline baron sa robe
était fendue en deux sur la poitrine et
jusqu'à mi cuisse et elle ramenait les
deux morceaux sur elle comme ça je lui
ai demandé est bien charline elle a
ouvert les yeux elle m'a répondu ça a
été plus fort que moi vous comprenez un
cauchemar il m'a violée ça le faisait
rire j'ai frappé je les tue et le crime
flagrant étant avéré je lui ai
immédiatement conduite à la gendarmerie
de louviers où j'ai demandé qu'un
médecin examine le rapport à cette
allégation de viol devait après
entre-temps par l'hôpital compterait
qu'était décès est décédé durant son
transport et que l'examen gynécologique
de l'inculpé faisait la preuve de
rapports sexuels rester une raison assez
simple
oui des questions merci vous supposez
monsieur l'adjudant de gendarmerie je
résume le rapport du médecin légiste
nombreuses contusions et fractures dont
une seule une seule est due à un coup
porté de bas en haut et l'écrasement de
la carotide tous les autres coups ont
été portés de haut en bas
quand la victime était à terre et parmi
ces coups là le coup sur l'occiput le
coup mart
cela confirme t-il vos constatations des
visions oui monsieur l'avocat général
merci monsieur l'adjudant de gendarmes
est ce que ma cliente vous a dit qu'elle
avait tué entraygues
ou est ce qu'elle vous a demandé si elle
l'avait tuée elle voulait demander vous
l'avait conduit directement la présence
de logos mais je ne vais pas proposé de
passer par la ferme pour il prendrait
vêtements et en basse à ses enfants
entre 2 et bien moi je pense qu'elle ne
voulait pas que ses enfants l'avoir
larmes avec sa robe déchirée soulier
enfin telle qu'elle avait vu en mai 54
sa mère un encore l'affluence
eh oui monsieur l'avocat général est
encore toujours cette fameuse scène
merci monsieur l'adjudant de la cour
vous remercie monsieur l'adjudant de
gendarmerie
le président cousine examiner la pièce à
conviction s'il vous plaît pensez vous
de la base vous plaît quels sont vos nom
prénom âge profession et domicile
ferrand réunit 43 ans gardien de nuit à
la jolie my hameau des clés annexe i
monsieur le président vous jouerez de
parler sans gêne et sans crainte de dire
toute la vérité rien que la vérité levé
la main droite et dit je le jure je le
jure bien vous allez être entendu sur
des faits criminels que de votre propre
initiative vous avez porté à la
connaissance de la justice qu'on vous
écoute et bien le 24 novembre 1978 j'ai
pris comme d'habitude mon service à la
jolie mal j'ai commencé ma ronde par le
bâtiment désaffecté du fond de la cour
et soudain j'ai entendu un hurlement ça
avait l'air de venir du regard bé c'est
une sorte d'entrepôt qui ne sert plus à
rien sauf aux voiliers du coin qui
viennent surtout landes
montrez nous entende et crié dans une
langue rbds et crié à la mort hurlaient
à la mort monsieur le président comme
dans l'aurès alors moi les cépages
je pousse la porte un massacre il y
avait là le pauvre charles par terre
détendu devant le dynamo oui de ben quoi
c'est un tas de chiffons ou les voiliers
du coup assez enfin vous me comprenez
monsieur présidence mais oui ont-ils eu
et bien il y avait du sang partout et là
charline le cognac comme une enragée
elle n'arrêtait pas de le cogner et de
le cogner avec sa part j'ai fait
l'algérie monsieur le président je crois
que je ne suis pas peureux mais là j'ai
sorti mon arme un frein au léman où je
te tire dedans elle a pas demandé son
reste l acheter sa barre sur le côté
rugueux j ai surtout ne baissent pas les
mains alors bien sûr que j'ai appelé les
gendarmes puis l'hôpital mais sens et
c'est vrai qu'avec mon arme pour qu'elle
laissait pas se sauver
essayez banon
des questions mais aussi riche résident
référence et hangars b ne les voyous
n'étaient pas les seuls à s'en servir
les messieurs et les dames de lusine ne
s'y donnait pas des petits rendez vous
mais là attention c'était pas pareil et
en bon gardien que vous êtes vous arrivé
de tomber au pire moment
oui mais en général le copain ils ne
mettent pas y aller et des services
qu'on se rentre comme quoi hein et et le
24 novembre la victime vous avez telle
demande est ce service annonce et
propose lucky man ray voulait dire paul
millot oui bien sûr président c'est lui
qui m'a dit la nouvelle de la part à
charlotte quel qu'il était dernier
d'amour avec la marchandise même que
j'ai dit ça s'arrose depuis comme ça la
démange jeanne d'arc
ça doit chauffer alors pendant ma ronde
et spacieuse
je suis allé plus loin accusé d'avoir
été distingué par des non maintenant
monsieur ferrand autre chose m coutet
voulais vous montrer la pièce à
conviction au témoin s'il vous plaît ni
différents cette barre
comment l'accusé la tenais tellement
vous l'avez vu vous vous en souvenez
vous rêvez pas réglementaire
un geste réfléchi geste de tueuse est l
effet d'audience monsieur l'avocat
général rien de plus dur est interrogé
le témoin motif
oui monsieur le président monsieur
ferrand à quelle heure vous avez vous
commencé cette ronde comme toujours à
18h30 salle non vous avertissent et la
gendarmerie à 18h24 six minutes avant de
l'avoir commencée il ya des fois que je
suis en avance quand ça quand on vous
signale un spectacle bien excitant à
regarder alors l'écouter jeu pas comme
ça mais ça m'était égal moins que qui
fricote ensemble pourtant vous déclarez
ça s'arrose depuis depuis le temps que
ça la démange jeanne d'arc savez ce jour
là ça soit qu'ils tombent peu à peu et
puis quand ça souffle pas bien c'est ça
se déchaîne pas et ça vaut la peine
c'est bien que vous êtes tout près quand
vous entendez ce fameux hurlements oui
elle était ton pas fermée mais pas non
pas vraiment enfin il y avait plus irait
donc à la tête ouverte retrouvèrent tout
comme ça comme ça mais plutôt juste ce
qu'il faut pour mater le viol
démaquillant je vous jure que je n'ai
rien vu juste le massacre bon pour tenir
ma cliente en respect à ce moment là est
ce que vous avez remarqué que sa robe
était déchirée elle est debout face à
vous et vous ne remarquez pas que sa
robe comme l'a dit l'adjudant
gendarmerie et fendue en deux sur la
poitrine et jusqu'à mi cuisse
enfin je veux pas la tête à ça
maintenant n'aviez pas non plus la tête
à se courir votre ami entraygues et bien
je vais vous dire moi vous aviez la tête
cette jeune femme qui pleure
haulotte vous la forcez sous la menace
de votre arme à rester debout mais au
dessus de la plaque devant 12 minutes
pour mieux profiter du spectacle enfin
moi je remercie monsieur le voyeur de
nuit non non non au tgv
non c est nous qu'est-ce que j'ai fait
monsieur le président vous pouvez vous
retirer
ferrand je souhaite néanmoins que vous
n'étiez pas la salle avant l'issue des
débats et mois suivant à mademoiselle
vernon bonjour mademoiselle vous voyez
des clones et vos nom prénom âge
profession et domicile
fernand martin julie 24 ans assembleuse
piqueuse 3 rue jean jaurès annexe i vous
jurer de parler sans rien et 100 g de
dire toute la vérité rien crédit a été
levé la main droite et dit je le jure ce
sujet la moselle dernier vous allez
déposer sur les événements dont vous
avez été témoin la jolie maï dans la
journée du 24 novembre 1978
la cour vous écoute je m'excuse si je
raconte mal j'ai pas trop la vie de
suite alors le 24 novembre ça mal
commencé dès qu'on est arrivé madame
raymond nous allons un des deux seuls
vrais mondes entre hug
oui elle nous a demandé de changer de
machine pour monter les chandails de
printemps alors tout de suite ça se met
à coincer à a ferraillé ma machine
surtout une vraie anti carrière mais son
président charline va chercher madame
raymonde alors raymond d'appel la
maintenance et nous
reste à causer quoi vous rappelez vous
le sujet de votre conversation
oui oui c'était de mai qu'il y avait un
peu bousculé une copine à la sortie d'un
bar
non mais des choses comme il en arrive
et tous les samedis soirs annexe i 1 moi
moi j'écoutais pour passer le temps et
puis et puis chars lourds est entré dire
charles entraygues entre amis non mais
non la pêche à l'omniprésident
tout de suite ils blaguent chalon mais
c'est à dire chaque fois qu'il la voyait
il me vient un clin d'oeil comme kangaba
vous savez en enroulant les mécaniques
pour se marier comme lui et puis et puis
lui disait alors chérissent aujourd'hui
tu me fait signe alors ce matin là elle
elle le traite de pauvre minable et elle
continue à discuter des ennuis de la
fille aux balles charlot is marier avec
moi elle elle répétait je vous dis que
c'est un viol alors alors tout d'un coup
il me donna un grand coup de coude comme
ça et lui dit mot prompt et tu t'y
connais poulette nom charline elle
devient tout rouge à elle le regarde
comme ça il a continué sur les sur les
filles qui en font un vrai pataquès
celles qui sont d'accord avant qu'ils
vont créer après au commissariat pour
pouvoir jouer les syndicaux chance en
riant l'est enfin sens privé on se
marrait bien loin on s'attendait charlie
cool mais comme elles faisaient toujours
mais là rien elle regarde la mer monte
elle lui dit [ __ ] et puis et puis il
ya eu la série du midi elle s'est sauvée
en courant avec madame raymond derrière
elle nous deux charlon
la cantine et est juste quand on entre à
la cantine vous la charlie dans la coag
raymonde elle lui écrit quelque chose
que tu le paieras puis avait avec
charlot elle le regarde en face comme ça
elle lui dit je veux qu'on s'explique
une bonne foi lui dis je les laisse
charlot il me retrouve à la table et il
me dit c'est bon pour moi monsieur
président à saillé poulette
elle m'a fait signe c'est pour ce soir
ces bonnes femmes
il faut les aider un peu pour qu'elle se
fasse plaisir voilà dieu s'est passé
ensuite
ben charlot il y retourne et la
maintenance et je n'ai plus revu et il
leur est si tu laisses une langue
je vous remercie question générale bien
nous avait raconté tous avaient charme
mais pouvez vous nous dire si votre
charles houle se vantait souvent à tort
de cette bonne fortune
il en avait bien assez devrait sans se
vanter de faire une touche quand tu
étais floor gamme mais quand il vous a
fait part de soi rendez vous avec
l'accusé il a ajouté
elle a fini par me faire signe qu'il
l'attendait donc ceci c'était une blague
entre eux ah parce qu'il blaguait tous
les doutes n'ont pas d'humour mais mais
lui oui et puis il blaguait toujours les
nouvelles comme gabin voyait il leur
disait de belles miches tu sais c'est un
peu un titre aux yeux m'enfin ça oui
d'accord mais charlot lui disait coluche
et c'était plus marrant peut servir la
même chose non et puis il aurait une
petite claque comme ça pour rire alors à
leur chant lead avec son sens de
l'humour elle le elle le regarde fait
heureusement bas les pattes elle lui dit
quand j'aurai envie d'un homme je te
ferai
les autres ça les a épaté mais selon lui
ils ces marais et depuis ils lui
demandaient toujours alors c'est
aujourd'hui que tu me fais signe le 24
novembre et de la feyssine le 24
novembre il y a crû lui hélas et vous y
avez vous pris bah oui c'est pas vrai je
vais le revoir parce que je voulais
m'expliquer c'est tout je lui dis devant
toi oui mais coûteux et il ya ce qu'on
fait il ya ce qu'on dit et moi ce que je
peux dire ben charlot celle qui lui
disaient non une bonne foi il assistait
pas où j'ai toujours dit non
bon oui parce que lorsque tu étais
copier d'avec sa femme sinon tu lui
aurait dit oui depuis longtemps notre
merci au président serbe
vous n'aviez pas beaucoup de sympathie
pour charlie n'est ce pas au début j'ai
essayé
elles étaient elles étaient toutes
faites dans son camp je voulais qu'on
soit copine mais elle m'a remise et
c'est comme si j'étais une comme je
m'excuse mais les filles qui n'ont pas
du moins et qui se croient merci c'est
pas mon jour c'était des des pétitions
pour une crèche à l' usine la pilule les
enfants martyrs l'accouchement sans
douleur des engueulades riz avec des
minables comme le gardien qui regardera
les douches à dans les deux châssis à
huy par un trou fait des bêtises quoi
nous les plus jeunes on ne l'avait
jusque-là mais charles en train de lui
il était de vos amis où je vais mais
bien ils se marraient tout le temps mais
enfin mais ça vous a pas paru étonnant
que charline baron donne un rendez vous
d'amour publiquement à un homme aussi
discret cepal aurait pu croire qu'il
ferait une exception pour elle elle
voulait faire bisquer management
et si c'était lui qui avait voulu vous
faire bisquer vous a pas de raison de
mentir je suis pas l'idiot
je sais pas de brouilla anoma et sa
femme pour caser avec lui et puis je
vais pas encore qui va me promener
devant le maire pour cinq minutes
passionnés
sipa von ah parce que vous croyez
qu'elle elle est folle je remercie mille
âmes généreuses et bien non vous pouvez
vous retirer ou alors s'asseoir dans la
salle où vous le désirez témoin suivant
ma venue et d'équidés vos nom prénom âge
profession et domicile
millau paul albert 39 ans ouvrier
rigueur h + 3 rue du du 18 juin nous
lier la mesure est de parler sans rien
et 100 g de dire toute la vérité rien
que la vérité
il avait la main droite et jure nos
joueurs allaient nous de la journée du
24 novembre 1978 et ben charmant
entrailles et moi on était arrivés
presque en même temps un joli mifare
7h30 on a laissé nos nos dames mal à
gris comme l'est toujours nos motos et
puis on s'est retrouvé dans l'eau dans
le bar qui est en passe de lusine pour
note flipper le tri peut alors y va
parce qu'on faisait une petite partie le
matin quoi histoire de se détendre avant
la journée puis pour en faire des des
connaissances plus te dire je crois d
des petites des petites demoiselles qui
attendait le bus on peut pas vu tout le
temps comme des sauvages
charles où il n'était pas sauvage
loisirs il aimait bien causer faire des
petits numéros c'était le le monde
vivant quoi alors quand
je suis arrivé il rigolait tout seul
alors je vais demander ce qu'il avait pu
il m'a dit c'est raymonde qui m'en a
raconté une bien bonne sur la mer
charline par une maladie dont on sait
bien on a rigolé que vous at il dit et
bien que que la merde baron il paraît
que c'était une drôle de coureuses à
epinal ou est-ce qu'être travailler
avant puisqu'elle avait un copain et
pique son sont 200 petits copains ils
l'avaient larié pour une magouille avec
un petit chef voilà donc l magnum
expliquez-vous mieux mais au tout et
tout et enfin si surface recommandé en
moi ce trafic qui vous dit sauvage
j'avais pu qui vous à lui qui court chez
les flics après voilà c'est csn ne
magouille et s'avoue divers qui s'est
beaucoup montré qu'ils vouent à badens
là je demande pardon année c'était
quelque chose
la mère du banc est de chercher des
crosses sans arrêt à tous les hommes de
deux usines
on pouvait même plus rigoler avec une
optique nouvelle sans kevin nous faire
de la morale elle vous voyez le mal
partout ce pain brun way au bâton
commando 1 qui sera menée à 3 dès qu'on
voulait raccompagner une nénette après
le bal c'est peut-être pas vrai ça il
faut se mettre à la place de charles
dussault président elle avait monté sa
dame qu'on contre lui est le chercher la
bagarre alors quand une femme comme ça
tu as avec ba c'est marrant on a envie
de raconter aux copains pour lui
rabattre un peu son caquet pas se
comprendre que le président mais oui
nous avions l'intention de raconter aux
copains comme vous dites est bien le
charlot il hésité à lui rapport à saddam
justement et puis c'est à ce moment là
qu'on a été dans 20 à l'atelier à
raymonde alors après on
on s'est retrouvé au dans le bistrot où
je mange moi le parce que la cantine
c'est par terry et ses lacunes qui m'a
dit charline c'est du tout cuit mais il
a employé cette expression
bah oui elle voulait c'était un rappel
aux hangars des à 6 heures alors nul le
soir on attendait au bistrot pour qu'ils
racontent bis et des gendarmes qui nous
ont raconté ce qui lui avait fait cette
espèce s'il vous plaît en juillet par
l'accusé bien des questions mais ça va
générer la question merci quotidien oui
merci mais chimio
n'avez-vous pas à plusieurs reprises
entre agh et vous interpellez ma cliente
en public en la traitant que la courbe
excuses de mal baisées et on ajoutant
qu'elle aurait besoin d'un homme pour la
cagnotte
des fois on lit les choses comme ça non
oui de l'occasion à ce rendez vous pour
la calmer un puce non plus risquer
plainte pour viol on n'avait jamais
parlé de la force et non non jamais non
non non on voulait juste lui donner une
petite leçon d'honnêteté quoi à quelle
leçon je crois de la viande à la cantine
et lui dire qu'on dirait son gros stress
il en avait un autre stratégie ans tous
les deux à bord ils voulaient lui faire
payer sociale sans nature et c'est ce
chantage que vous osiez après le souper
au nom le système c'était pour après et
quoi pas qu'elles le sont elle va vous
n'osez pas dire ouais
et pourquoi quand je vous aurais pour
susi voilà une fois qu'ils auront fait
leur petite affaire ensemble
il voulait lui dire en se marrant qui
avale et pas plus cher que toutes deux
les autres et qui garderait ne reste
rien du tout
charles baron
montrez que vous at il soumis à ce
chantage ça at il promis le silence en
échange de vos faveurs pour vous
apprendre ensuite qu'il s'était mais qui
êtes vous non ça s'est pas passé comme
ça ça s'est passé comme je les dis
s'épargnant vous pouvez vous retirer
youpi retourner à bout flipper sur 10
mois suivant madame audrey
vous avez vous approché de la barre s'il
vous plaît madame payée décliner vos nom
prénom âge profession et domicile
entrait gréement 47 ans commerçante 27
bis avenue de la république à louviers
même vous êtes la veuve de la victime
vous ne vous êtes pas constituée partie
civile
je vais vous entendre sur la foi du
serment j'aurais de parler sans rien et
sans crainte de dire toute la vérité
rien que la vérité ait levé la main
droite et dit je le jure j'agis en est
il exact madame que dans la nuit du 23
novembre 1978 vous ayez rapporter à
votre mari une confidence de charline
baron sur certains événements de son
passé je croyais bien faire monsieur le
président charles il m'avait tellement
aidé à son arrivée à joly maille avant
je me sentais une moins que rien je
faisais semblant de savoir quand les
filles où c'est j'avais tellement peur
de perdre mon cher vous avez bien plus
serrée qui tu as oui je sais on a dit
que c'était pour me le prendre je sais
bien mais ça je n'ai jamais cru elle me
disait que j'avais pas de dignité
quand on se sent vieillir la dignité
mais enfin à force de se voir entre nous
des filles comme moi comme elle ce mail
à me reprendre
charles est venu chercher style que je
le dois
mais pardonnez moi madame je je je
comprends pas très bien là mais il
tenait à moi monsieur le président quand
il m'a plu vu chez lui à lui faire des
petits plats à l'écouter raconter ses
fredaines il a compris qui tu es à moi
je dis pas qu après il sait pas encore
le beau temps vous vous dites vous nous
dites que vous aviez de la
reconnaissance pour l'accuser cependant
au site où vous vous brouillez avec elle
pas moi c'est elle qui me gardaient
rancune de quoi être aussi lâche avec
mon mari je te jure que ça me faisait
mal de vous voir comme deux ennemis de
l'entente de traiter de megève un soir
c'est vrai j'ai pas pu tenir ma langue
et je lui ai dit et raison d'être comme
ça pas aimable avec les sommes méfiants
mais quels étaient ces raisons et
s'était fait violer et que personne ne
voulait la croire même pas son ami
c'est ça j'ai dit charline je te jure
j'ai cru mourir mourir de honte quand il
l'a taquiné à propos de son secret il
était pas méchant mon charme
je voulais faire le malin j'ai essayé de
l'expliquer mais c'est à dire et 12h01
midi on s'entend de l'atelier charles
plus on lui répondait quand il faisait
le malin et plus il en rajoute et je le
lui ai bien dit après mais elle m'a
répondu que c'était son affaire à elle
toute seule maintenant je les supplier
de ne pas lui donner rendez-vous sans
moi je savais bien que tu as bagard et
que ça finirait mal qu'il l'a violerait
il n'a pas pu faire ça la secouer un peu
bon une petite bagarre mais une femme
qui n'a pas eu de rapports depuis six
ans se laisse aller quand à belhom la
chahutent dit le charline dictats yacht
à cause de moi je te connais tu as eu
peur qu'il me raconte tout après et a vu
rouge mais ne dit pas quitte à violer
mouche
c'était une ordure ton chat mais tu le
sais bien
non non non non je vous en prie les
questions mais c'est vrai que j'aime
bien ta question merci conscience non
mais c'est précisé
bien à court vous remercie madame vous
pouvez regagner votre domicile ou les
assurés dans la salle si vous le désirez
témoin suivant
alors madame le loup payer décliner
bruno prénom âge profession et domicile
madame madeleine et part aucune petite
anissa to play voulais vous parler un
peu plus fort
le loup madeleine née baron cultivatrice
à ouville le haut
né le 10 janvier 51 vous êtes madame la
sueur de l'accusé vous ne pouvez pas
déposé sous la foi du serment à court at
on vous entendra trittin titre de
renseignements sur la personnalité de
votre soeur dans nos pas nous attarder
sur votre enfance commune à epinal qui
n'a pas été très heureuse nous le savons
mais plutôt sur votre vie avec votre
soeur à partir de 1960 quand elle est
entrée à textile unis l'avouer mais
qu'est ce que je dois dire comment vous
viviez maman faisait encore des ménages
enfin plus beaucoup parce qu'elle avait
pas tellement de courage depuis que papa
était parti comme je n'avais plus de
santé c'est pas pareil beaucoup de
charline était devenu le chef de famille
forcément on vivait sur sa pelle soigner
moment elle m'emmenait partout avec elle
quand elle sortait sûreté beaucoup en
1963 combat au bal au ciné je vis
faisait tourner la tête à tous les
garçons textile unis mais elle était
sérieuse puis d'ailleurs elle s'immisce
presque tout de suite en ménage avec
dune ou alors j'ai pas très bien compris
pourquoi parce que c'était un vrai père
pantoufles jaloux avec ça même de ces
gosses
elle a bien fait de le quitter ce
n'était pas une grosse perte
oui même même pour ses enfants a lille
on jamais réclamés après leur père sa
vie et qu'elle était liée avec raymond
d'entraygues pas dit qu'ils avaient du
malheur quelque part elle prenait sur
ses épaules alors redmond elle en a
profité comme les autres notre soeur l'a
bien amenée chez vous enfin je veux dire
chez votre grand-mère le 15 janvier 1978
toujours ça peut traîner
trait d'union cherchait vraiment des
echards link à porter le chapeau il a
appelé ce mec de merde je m'excuse mais
en partant il lui a crié trop ma
poulette je retourne en fais moi
confiance
même le loup vous rappelez vous avoir
été réveillée une nuit par une scène
horrible autres vous parle monsieur si
horrible que votre soeur a couru
chercher les gendarmes
oui je me souviens des gendarmes des
gendarmes seulement aucune autre image
il revient en 54 le témoin avait trois
ans votre client il se souvient d'un tas
de petits détails de sa vie à cet âge
est le témoin aurait oublié une scène
aussi importante aussi traumatisante
qu'elle avait vraiment mieux sérieux m
monsieur le président est ce que je peux
demander que on rappelle le batteur de
courcy qui est encore dans la salle du
château demain voulez vous revenir la
barre ses troupes et docteurs et
qu'est-ce que je serais vous je restais
là ce avait encore des questions à poser
aux témoins merci madame vous pouvez
entre place dans la salle si vous le
désirez terre et vous avez dit tout à
l'heure que ma cliente avait une mémoire
sélective
est ce que c'est un cas particulier non
nous avons tous tendance dès notre plus
jeune âge à nous rappeler ce qui nous
fait du bien et à oublier ce qui nous
fait du mal
imaginons un enfant de trois ans que sa
mère abandonne la mère pleure
cet enfant pourra t'il se rappeler plus
tard les larmes de sa mère s'il aime sa
mère évidemment est un enfant du même
âge qui aime son père
pourra-t-il oublier une scène très
importante nous le père a joué un rôle
très déplaisant un sujet bien adapté
pour à l'oublier oui mais a jugé
introverti angoissé comme votre cliente
aura du mal à se souvenir peut resurgir
à tout moment et le paralyser le
ministère public ne peut donc pas tiers
avaient tiré harriman
oubli de madame le loup pour conclure
que ma cliente a inventé de toutes
pièces le viol conjugal de metz à 24 du
point de vue psychiatrique ce ne serait
pas un argument bien valable
heureusement m le docteur m'a fourni
d'autres puis je regagner ma place
nouvelle
la cour vous en prie docteur et mois
suivant oui je précise qu'avec ce
témoigner je précise qu'avec ce témoin
nous revenons à la plainte pour viol
déposée en soixante dix à epinal par
l'accusé contre georges de route
veuillez dégainez vos nom prénom âge
profession et domicile mme lemonnier
jean-pierre 57 ans inspecteur de police
en retraite villa l'hirondelle traverse
du pescadous à allauch bouches-du-rhône
même juré de parler sans crainte de dire
toute la vérité rien que la vérité levé
la main droite et dit je te jure je le
jure monsieur l'officier de police le 8
mars 1970 vous étiez attachés au
commissariat de police de quartier des
abeilles dans la périphérie nord
d'epinal oui monsieur le président j'ai
reçu moi-même charline baron et bien
qu'il ne subsiste plus de trace de ça
plane dans nos archives
la plaignante l'ayant retirer j'ai
retrouvé une note la concernant dans un
dossier confidentiel à usage des jeunes
inspecteurs
maintenant nous résumer le lisais pas
c'est bien monsieur le président
charline baron s'est donc présenté au
commissariat le
8 mars 1970 à 16 heures 15 environ elle
m'a déclaré qu'un contremaître de son
usine georges leroux l'avait agressée
sexuellement le 7 mars chez elle à 22h
en l'absence de son compagnon henri
dumont le cependant elle était incapable
de décrire la scène avec précision et
les quelques détails qu'elle donnait
sembler bizarre
ainsi le roux avait déchiré sa robe
disent elles mais cette robe déchirée
elle avait jeté après le départ de
monsieur dont elle avait subi
passivement l'assaut ce monsieur l'avait
reçu de bon gré à l'insu de son
compagnon à une heure qui incite à se
montrer galant
surtout s'il est un ancien amant de la
davrays leroux n'a jamais été mon amant
je regrette sa figure est sur votre
fiche
quelle fut sa fiche de police monsieur
le président charline baron avait été
interpellé plusieurs fois depuis 68 pour
affichage sauvage distribution de tracts
rébellion à agent elle était dans le
fichier c'est la routine bah voyons
non vous aviez consultez cette fiche
alors qu'elle venait porter plainte dans
son intérêt monsieur le président si je
me souviens bien sa fiche était
accablante inconduite notoire de 62 à 64
fréquentation assidue de bars et de
dancing mal famés notamment accompagné
du sur l'euro c'est un vrai aux
informateurs étaient dignes de foi ou d
un tic du voisin des voisins des
ouvriers textiles unis comme elle elle
aurait même songé à s'établir avec le
rosé par avant de choisir le sueur du
monde je les mises en garde contre les
conséquences d'une plate mal fondées que
cusimer son concubinage
ces enfants n'ont reconnu entachées de
suspicion légitime nous enfin votre rôle
se bornait enregistré à transmettre au
parquet monsieur respectueux et parfums
mais monsieur le président du temps
submergé de plaintes aboutissant à des
classer sans suite ou des non lieux je
voulais donner à cette femme le temps de
se raviser
la manne sa plainte gefla mais à textile
unige après que que le roux était très
estimé de ses supérieurs et que baron
était une
portant des accusations gratuites contre
lui pour provoquer des remous dans une
assemblée du personnel au mais à qui
voulez-vous faire grassi ragots en tout
à son syndicat lui même le croyait part
on lui reconnaissait bien va demander
une explication le rouge jeudi a reconnu
que qu'il avait demandé une explication
à baron le 7 mars
elle avait alors invité à venir
s'expliquer le le soir même nom d'herbes
et marron ou par s'user moi je
confondais avec un autre rendez vous n'a
bravo bref cette plainte pour viol santé
le commenter dfa d'agitation politique
j'ai fait dire à baron que je ne voulais
pas de ça dans mon secteur et qu'elle
ferait bien de venir me voir avant que
je transmette sa dénonciation
calomnieuse au parquet elle l'a fait me
pouvant ainsi que j'avais eu raison
j'ai déchiré sa plainte à sa demande
voilà rien d'autre à dire déchets le
président oui mais enfin vous êtes tous
à ce que c'était au magistrat
instructeur d'une façon un peu abusive
le sud un spectacle mais c'est assez
ennuyeux ça j'ai anticipé
je le reconnais enfin les questions sauf
que généralement peu de questions m
inspecteur à manier vous étiez submergé
plainte pour viol combien en avez-vous
reçu 170 montre 69 et 70 une vingtaine
il y avait surtout des travailleurs
immigrés et de jeunes délinquants est ce
que vous receviez toujours vos
plaignante comme vous aviez reçu
charline par an oui m il est facile
d'accuser au hasard par hystérie ou
malveillance a fait face il a vraiment
en 70 sur 100 femmes violées 9 seulement
aux porté plainte et je cite là une
enquête du ministère de la justice les
enquêtes statistiques oui vous préfériez
les vôtres sans doute d'emblée vous
traiter ma cliente en coupable parce
qu'elle a une fiche dans vos services
non m non parce que son récit ne tenait
pas debout je vais parler crûment mais
techniquement c'est une femme vous pas
un homme ne peut pas ou alors ça laisse
des traces et votre client que savait si
bien qu'elle s'est comporté en coupe non
messieurs en victime
dix familles par votre enquête partiale
nourrit de ragots et de contre vérités
dites moi pour servir quels intérêts
cette enquête celui de la justice maître
sur votre cliente n'avait écouté attend
le se serait épargné bien des
humiliations
elle n'aurait pas eu si peur que la
vérité éclate au grand jour il ne serait
peut-être pas là où elle est permettez
un vieux policier de vous le dire à
évitons pas titre à savoir si l'un sinon
s'il vous plaît sinon je fais évacuer la
salle bien pouvez vous retirer monsieur
le fichier de police
le je désire cependant que vous restiez
dans la salle jusqu'à la fin des débats
et à tous les témoins cités on était en
voiture ont été entendus mais mesdames
et messieurs les jurés ont viennent de
faire savoir que madame gisèle vincent
qui a suivi des débats demandant d'être
entendu sur la plainte en viol déposée
par charles baron contre le roux
jugerait dont deux mots pouvoir
discrétionnaire pour entendre ce témoin
une objection diamètre côté veuillez
s'il vous plaît madame thomassin barre
bien madame payée de gêner vos nom
prénom âge profession et domicile
vincent gisèle 28 ans ouvrière 3 rue de
la république à epinal madame votre
déposition figurera à titre de
renseignement
je vous demanderais cependant de
témoigner sous la foi du serment
connaissiez d'accuser avant les faits
madame
et oui enfin un peu bien vous aurez de
parler sans rien et sans crainte de dire
toute la vérité rien que la vérité levé
la main droite et dit je te jure le jir
un coup vous écoute la dame
je ne sais pas bien comment vous
connaissiez dont l'accusé en mars 70 oui
je l ai vu une fois ou deux en mars à
texter l'unique ans quand ça lui est
arrivé
oui quand elle a été licenciée oui enfin
j'étais apprenti au piquage forcément on
parler d'elle à cause de de cette
histoire de viol
tandis de temps on la croyait pas trop
jusqu'à ce jusqu'à je vous demande
pardon monsieur je n'y arrive pas
personne ne sait que je suis ici même
pas mon mari cet hiver enfin je peux
dire que c'est ce matin je me suis
décidé à prendre le train et maintenant
je vous troubler pas madame mon voilà
j'ai lu dans le journal que mademoiselle
barre en serez jugés aujourd'hui pour
avoir tué son violeur et le président de
la cour de signaler à ce témoin
spontanée si je puis dire que la chose
n'étant pas jugée elle s'expose à des
poursuites judiciaires
entre atteint la victime de violeurs ou
pour monsieur entrer que je ne sais pas
mais pour monsieur leroux je sais il me
l'a dit il nous a dit quoi qu'il a
violée
vous témoigner sous la foi du serment
n'essayez pas la timide et de témoins
votre maison s'il vous plaît ne
l'interrompe et ni l'un ni l'autre des
madame j'attire votre attention sur
l'importance de votre témoignage
quand le roux vous aurait-il fait cet
aveu
bon voilà en mai 70 j'ai été affecté au
tissage dans l'atelier de l'euro et oui
cette hausse oui of non non c'est en
juillet le 13 la veille de mon congé
forcé moi je me souviens il vous avez
gardé après leur qui nous aller les
ouvrières ses filles pour tout ranger et
moi il m'a fait rester après les autres
soit disant que j'avais bâclé mon
travail je me méfiais pas un homme qu'on
connaît même monsieur l'euro c'est vrai
qu'on ne peut pas raconter mais j'avais
j'avais fini de ranger
il était derrière moi il m'a plaquée
contre lui ces masses sur ma poitrine
mais il m'a fait tomber
je ne voulais pas mais je ne pouvais
rien un homme de très bien même quand
une femme ne veut pas supporter cali
mission d'inspecteurs leroux a fait ce
qu'il a voulu et pourtant je me suis
débattu comme une folle il vous a parlé
de charles lindbergh
oui monsieur le président il sera juste
est devant moi et il m'a dit une femme
qui se défend c'est plus excitant que
charline qui était resté comme une mante
lui pardonner mais s'il n'a rien dit de
plus madame c'est un rapport sexuel
qu'il avouait par un viol
quand une femme est comme une morte
l'absence de participation n'implique
pas qu'il y ait une violence au le
ministère public les canards consentent
c'est nouveau ce que je sais c'est qu'il
m'a violée moi c'est pas facile à dire
oui je ne vais pas porter plainte parce
qu'il m'a dit il m'a dit ne fait pas de
bêtise ne court pas chez les flics pour
nous faire des ennuis après laffaire
chez en ligne les ennuis c'est toi qui
les aura et puis je j'ai préféré oublier
tous âges et j'ai quitté l'usiné
tellement j'avais honte
j'étais fiancée à l'époque j'ai rompu
je ne pouvais plus supporter qu'un homme
me touche vous êtes pourtant marié oui
depuis 76 euros et est mort alors bien
madame je ne sais pas si je sais pas
comment appeler ça votre récit sert
vraiment la justice en tout cas ici à la
défense miraculeusement ouimet président
madame je ne déposerai qu'une seule
question est-ce que c'est par crainte de
l'euro que le 13 juillet 70 vous n'avez
pas dénoncer le crime qu'il a commis sur
vous pour qu'on ne me croie pas raconter
les détails à ce moment là je n'ai pas
eu le courage madame et en revenant ici
c'est c'est d'écouter tout le monde et
surtout mademoiselle baroux qui dit
qu'on ne la crois pas ce n'est pas juste
messieurs c'est ça qui m'a décidée
je vous remercie madame lagourgue
remercie madame je vais vous retirer
bientôt des témoins ont été entendus
monsieur l'avocat général vous avez la
parole pour vos réquisitions
c'est le président mesdames et messieurs
de la cour
mesdames et messieurs les jurés il est
difficile de sonner le réveil après ce
coup de théâtre de dernière heure de
toute dernière heure c'est tout jeune
femme tellement bouleversée n'est ce pas
m qui vient nous compter qu'il ya des
années elle a été violée peut-être
charline baron l'a été aussi auparavant
que l'émotion après tant d'épreuves la
vertu émerge enfin des sombres nuée de
la persécution et du vice mais s'il vous
plaît laissons se dissiper ce rideau de
fumée qui camoufle une réalité qui
dérange et nous verrons apparaître une
toute autre image une image terrible
celle du meurtre d'un homme charles
entraîne car c'est un meurtre il me
semble que quand on a beaucoup publié
jusqu'ici c'est un meurtre qui vaut à
charles baron de comparaître aujourd'hui
devant le docteur de courcy nous l'a dit
quoique saine d'esprit elle s'est
enfermée dans son mandat elle dit à
laurent sa propre justice a le elle ne
se considère un peu comme un ange
d'humbles mortels comme do peuvent-ils
se permettre de juger un ange nous
allons tout de même essayer en examinant
d'un oeil raisonnable la vie de sainte
charline célibataire et martyr petite
fille marty ne semble pas la grand mère
l'élève la mer ne l'abandonnent pas on
nous l'a dit mais la mère n'abandonne
pas non plus son mari et sa l'enfant ne
l'admet pas on juge le père coupable on
cherche un exécuteur s'adresse à dieu
arnaud veine mais ça ne marche pas le
coupable n'est pas foudroyé et puis
arrive la fameuse scène si chère à la
défense
un soir la journée a été dure le père
rentre tard il est toujours avoir une sa
femme il est peut-être un peu trop
pressants eh ben ça y est flagrant délit
violent en cours chez les gendarmes
on a dû les trouver en l'occasion plus
efficace plus efficiente le bon dieu
mais le père lui et que récente alors
yat-il viol il n'y a toujours pas mort
d'homme mais il y à déjà élimination on
se retrouve dans shake de famille les
années passent tout semble aller pour le
mieux on peut faire marcher les garçons
ça leur apprendra que l'on sent choisi
en résumant bien braves qui vous fait
aujourd'hui deux enfants dont on lui
refuse la paternité pas de père toujours
pas mort d'homme mais encore élimination
ça puis voilà qu'on apprend contremaître
à l' usine georges l'euro 1 trousseur de
jupon un homme affecte il faut le
chasser
alors on s'adresse à la direction mais
ça ne marche pas pu la rive 68 on se
fait des disciples l'ange déploie ses
ailes on dénonce le dragueur l'homme
affecte on lui interdit de courtiser les
filles sous peine d'être chassé de son
travail il désobéit alors on s'adresse
non plus à dieu non plus aux gendarmes
n'ont plus à la direction mais où
syndicats et là il faut des preuves
alors alors on va tâcher d'accuser le
roux de viol une menace habilement
proférer quelques jours avant une
réunion importante syndicales le pousse
à vouloir s'expliquer on s'arrange pour
le recevoir chez soi à une heure tardive
propice aux épanchements on engage la
conversation
sans trop de bridoire n'est pas encore
très sûr et puis on cède aux avances de
l'homme il faut pas traumatiser les
enfants n'est ce pas et puis à minuit le
concubin revient lui parle de rien le
lendemain à l usine on prend le vent
semble que le syndicat ne soit pas très
près de lâcher leur ou alors en sortant
du travail en fin d'après midi on va
porter plainte officiellement pour viol
mais hélas la police n'y crois pas le
syndicat non plus tout tombe à plat et
on nous l'a dit on a honte d'avoir été
si bête alors on suit epinal ont fait
son concubin ont pu dit lui arrachant
ses enfants d'abord yat-il viol n'a pas
encore mort d'homme mais il ya encore
élimination trois ans plus tard on
rencontre de nouveau à la jolie mike
holmes à epinal un homme infecte un
dragueur un charmeur dont la femme
amoureuse est amoureuse et ils peuvent
pas se ferment les yeux sur les petites
fredaines de son mari il ya là un amour
un amour profond
nous l'avons vu alors il faut le
détruire on croit punir en très grands
en lui arrachant sa femme après après
l'avoir circonvenu hélas madame en trek
trahi la cause en préférant son mari
plus que sa pire le 24 novembre on
s'aperçoit contre eg c'est connaît la
bêtise d'epinal là sa famille a tout
raconté alors là là il faut le faire
taire il faut le faire taire alors on un
seul séduire il le croit tout le monde
le croit d'ailleurs mais madame entre
aigle croix et le soir on lui donne
rendez vous pour le soir devant le radar
b en gare à la réputation bien établie
et le soir charline baron en trek vous
retrouve devant le hangar b il pleut ça
vous arrange vous entrez entraygues ne
ferme pas la porte comme il le fait s'il
avait l'intention de vous violez vous
pouvez vous échappez vous connaissez
lusine vous pouvez crier le le gardien
n'est pas loin de ce pas m mais vous
continuez la conversation et puis vous
entrez dans votre état second et vous
céder pourquoi
pour acheter son silence vous savez que
c'est un vantard et qu'il racontera tout
d'ailleurs à point nommé vous sortez de
votre état second pour l'entente dont
vous déclarez avec bonne humeur que ma
foi il ne va pas garder pour lui le
moment qu'il vous doit et l'ange pur et
dur que vous être en sa justice et cette
fois elle ne s'adresse qu'à lui pour
l'exécuter il tue y at il eu viol même
en admettant cette fois charline baron
il ya mort d'homme je sais bien
vous ne vous souvenez pas de votre
acharnement à frapper vous perdez la
mémoire et vous la retrouvez quand ça
vous arrange
mais le coup avec lequel d'abord vous
avait écarté votre assaillants puis le
coup avec lequel ensuite vous l'avez tué
ses coups vous l'avez les avait donnés
avec une des barres de fer dont le
hangar était plat ce que tout le monde
savait l usine
charline bar on vous tue peut-être dans
cet état de panique ne nous a parlé le
docteur du court si vous tuez sûrement
pour éliminer celui qui symbolise pour
vous le le plaisir la vie vous tuez
surtout parce que cette histoire de viol
si bien organisé vous permet croyez-vous
de rendre d'exécuter votre justice en
toute impunité
alors que dire que nul n'a le droit de
se faire justice que nul n'a le droit
d'imposer sa propre idée de la justice
monsieur le président madame et monsieur
de la cour mesdames et messieurs les
jurés
si nous confortons charline baron dans
son rôle de justicier qui sait quand
pourquoi au nom de quel crime inventé
par elle elle va frapper de nouveau son
système de défense est devenu un système
d' attaque
cette femme est dangereuse nous pouvons
lui témoigner de l'indulgence état
d'urgence qui lui est si étrangère mais
notre devoir est de protéger la société
c'est pourquoi je requiers contre
charline baron
une peine de réclusion criminelle qui ne
puisse en aucun cas être inférieur à 10
ans
je
la parole est à m simonetti pour la
défense il y a eu mort d'homme certes il
y a eu mort d'homme
sinon ce n'est pas charline c'est un
autre qui serait dans ce box
cette femme a tué c'est vrai mais avant
de la juger monsieur le président madame
et messieurs de la cour mesdames et
messieurs les jurés n'est-il pas de
notre devoir à tous de découvrir le
véritable élément moteur qui a poussé
cette femme à cette extrémité depuis que
je lui rends visite dans sa prison où
elle est enfermée séparée de ses enfants
depuis le 24 novembre 1978 un mot
n'obsède et pendant tous ces débats ce
mot revient et s'impose à moi comme il
s'impose à vous j'en suis sûr le moa
justice la justice charline sûreté des
saints petite enfance mais je suis
d'accord avec monsieur l'avocat général
n'a pas été une enfant martyr mais
rejeté par son père et par sa mère dès
sa naissance sa wii elle l'a été c'est
indéniable peut-être trouvé sa juste on
lui dit que sa mère a commis un péché et
qu'elle a dû se marier pour préserver
l'honneur de la famille mais plus tard à
epinal elle constate que sa mère est
insulté accusé de s'être fait et vous
êtes force qu'elle est malade
enceinte à longueur d'année alors
qu'elle risque d'en mourir et que le
père s'en moque drago café et invite ses
maîtresses à dîner chez sa femme qui
leur fait la cuisine et on leur donne de
le respecter
ce père si peu respectables peut-être
trouvé sa juste
une nuit le 12 mai 54 elle est réveillée
par les cris de sa mère qui repousse son
père toujours amoureux de sa femme nous
dit monsieur l'avocat général forcé une
femme qui dit non sous prétexte que
c'est votre femme et que vous pouvez en
faire ce que vous voulez quand vous
voulez c'est tout de même une curieuse
conception de l'amour pénétrer une femme
en la brutalise ans ça s'appelle un viol
elle ne le sait pas cette petite fille
de 10 ans mais ça lui paraît intolérable
alors elle a recours à la justice a va
chercher les gendarmes
ça lui fait rire c'est sa femme voyons
il a tous les droits
étonnez vous après ça que charline dix
ans plus tard choisissent un homme qui
veuille bien attendre qu'elle lui dise
oui moi aussi j'ai envie de toi
en 1960 elle est devenue chef de famille
est oui à 16 ans elle travaille en usine
sera peut enfin on l'aperçoit avec un
garçon aussi tourner en fait son amant
et un texte unique est ce qu'elle voit
des petits chefs qui abusent de leur
pouvoir pour faire renvoyer les
ouvrières qui refusent de coucher avec
eux alors 68 a réagi avec ses camarades
demande et à l'obtention de plus de
justice
seulement quand elle rend comme en cent
soixante dix on se bat pour préserver
les emplois et pour les conserver alors
la dignité de quelques femmes c'est pas
un très bon terrain de lutte c'est pas
une bonne tactique on la lâche ont fait
mieux
on prévient le roux et on lui dit une
petite conversation pourrait tout
arranger alors elle le reçoit aller à
tort ça oui mais toutes les femmes
violées vous le diront un homme
on connaît c'est impensable kivu violent
et pourtant le roux prend de force
cette femme inerte alors a dû trier
avant nous dit monsieur l'avocat général
avant quoi c'est quand le bon moment
charline vous a dit j'étais paralysée
j'ai revu mon père et ma mère et le
docteur de courcy vous l'a dit se
souvenir il n'est pas effacé les temps
fouilles près à ressurgir après le jaune
charline jet sa robe soyeuse assez
bizarres des inspecteurs de manier bah
non c'est pas bizarre toutes les femmes
violées vous le diront on veut se laver
eh oui se laver
alors on jette sa robe soulier parce que
on peut pas jeter son corps
comment raconter ça et comment s'étonner
que charline part d'un peu à se rendre
au commissariat
la dernière fois qu'elle s'est adressé à
la police on a ri et bien haut
commissariat des abeilles on fera pire
on ressort une fiche de police
on lui dit calmement on lui dit qu'elle
est et provocante consentante
on lui dit qu'elle a inventé tout ça
pour nuire à leur sont saint tricat
soumis à la pression et au chantage de
l'inspecteur lemonnier ne veut pas la
croire ça le dérange son compagnon ne la
crois pas ça te dérange
la pression est telle qu'elle va retirer
sa plainte mais corrombles elle sera pas
même renvoyé sans indemnité et sans
préavis touche l'ont abandonné peut-être
trouvé sa juste alors elle s'en va avec
ses enfants
et après trois longues années
d'insécurité moral et matériel
la voilà un joli maille et là c'est le
règne des petits jeunes qui roulent des
mécaniques benon se sont pas de mauvais
bougre monsieur l'avocat général
seulement une femme qui leur cloue le
bec comme dit martin garneau va ça les
dérange
et pourtant c'est là qu'elle va trouver
l'amitié et même l'affection du reymond
d'entraygues cette femme tendre
généreuse qu'elle identifie à sa mère et
ce jose d'epinal se souvenir qu'ils
empoisonnent elle le raconte
hélas vraiment d'intrigué la femme d'un
petit coq de village qu'il voit dans
cette histoire de jeunes l'occasion
idéale pour rabattre son caquet à une
femme qui lui a toujours dit non
et voilà le secret de charline
transformer en magouilles et en
plaisanteries de bistrot charline veut
rétablir la vérité
charles entraygues prend ça pour une
invitation à l'amour c'est pas sa faute
il conditionné pour lui les femmes ne
pense
ça alors on monte un coup entre copains
et millau lui dit de lui dont une bonne
leçon d'honnêteté
on vous a expliqué ce que ça voulait
dire et charles entraygues laisse la
porte du hangar entre ouverte oui pour
qu'elle ne se méfie pas et pour que son
ami ferrand puissent venir jouir du
spectacle et les voilà seuls
elle lui parle comme elle a parlé à
raymonde mais il ne la crois pas son
récit l'ex-site et il la viole
là aussi elle aurait dû crier avant
n'est ce pas savez vous que sur 100
femmes violées par des hommes qu'elles
connaissent
45 sont si choqué au sens clinique du
terme qu'elles ne peuvent pas réagir
charline est retombé dans son cauchemar
elle est paralysée qu'est-ce qui la
réveille
rires eh oui le rire de cet imbécile
assez fat pourquoi qu'il lui a rendu
service
alors là elle ne sait plus où elle est
elle ne sait plus rien
elle ne sait plus qu'une chose il faut
que ce rire s'arrête
il y à une barre de fer sous sa mère
elle ne sait pas qu'elle est en train de
tuer gisèle vincent violet vous a dit
après j'avais perdu la tête
charles baron violet vous a dit je ne
savais plus où j'étais il faut la croire
raymond d'entraygues
elle l'a cru elle nous l'a prouvé elle
ne s'est pas porté partie civile
elle a compris que charline avait frappé
dans un état de détresse extrême sans
volonté de tuer elle va pardonnez moi ce
n'est pas le pardon que j'attends de
vous c'est l'équité c'est pourquoi
monsieur le président je vous
demanderais d'user de votre pouvoir
discrétionnaire pour poser la question
des coups mortels
monsieur l'avocat général a raison nul
n'a le droit d'imposer sa propre idée de
la justice mais cela charline ne l'a
jamais fait la justice elle a attendu
toute sa vie aujourd'hui monsieur le
président madame et monsieur de la cour
mesdames et messieurs les jurés la
justice elle attend de vous
charline baron levé vous avez vous
quelque chose à ajouter pour votre
défense
ça servirait à rien vous ne croyez pas
les débats sont terminées bien même le
premier juré que pensez vous de cette
affaire
quelle est votre opinion c'est un cas
très dramatique où je pense que la
société est en jeu cette jeune femme a
été traumatisée depuis sa plus tendre
enfance par le viol dont elle même fut
victime un peu plus tard pour épargner
des scènes abominable à ses enfants elle
a été comprise rejetée elle n'a pas
assez et n'a pas été assez secourus
quand elle était en détresse et je pense
que notre devoir est de la rendre ses
enfants oui bien en ce qui me concerne
je trouve que le cas insiste
particulièrement sur les rapports assez
spéciaux disons en de l'accusé par
rapport à la société aussi bien nous qui
la jugeons que son milieu d'où il vient
et où elle a été mêlé alors si les
motivations semblent assez personnelle
puisqu'il s'agit d'abord et avant tout
d'agression contre sa personne
il me semble que on doit noter
l'important justement qu'après son
milieu sur elle et qui a pu l'influencer
je trouve que c'est un problème très
touffu très délicat moi je serais très
très bref je le rejoindrai en cela
malgré tout les deux des deux dames qui
sont à côté de moi pour moi tout le
problème est de savoir si charlie est un
coupable entre guillemets ou une victime
entre dilma également c'est tout ce que
j'ai à dire pour l'instant
sur 12 mois le meurtre de chars
d'entraygues et y ait nécessairement
souvenir de viol de sa mère également au
coeur de son propre orgueil par georges
leroux mais je trouve que quand même la
sphère des plupart des témoignages assez
peu crédible ensemble et c'est pour ça
que j'aimerais qu'on revienne 7 à
témoignage oui celui de viol
oui je pense qu'il est un peu tôt pour
que je puisse se donner un sentiment
précis sur cette affaire je préfère
attendre pochât tout pour moi cette
femme a mené toute sa vie avec le
souvenir du drame qu'elle a vu étant
enfant et est là qu'ils ont mené sa vie
dans le sens qu'elle a voulu aider les
autres femmes
et c'est comme ça qu'elle a fait du
féminisme comme disaient les témoins et
je pense que disent qu'ils ont ce rôle
qu'elle a mené trouve que c'est une
femme ils ont intelligente une femme qui
a un qui ne recherchait pas ce que
certains hommes lui ont reproché c'est à
dire des aventures et je pense en toute
bonne foi que si elle a vécu est
vraiment de des viols à tous points de
vue je pense effectivement que elle a
vécu des choses assez terrible est que
apparemment dans les témoins il n'y a
pas beaucoup de gens qui l'aiment et
donc qui en essayant de se décharger eux
mêmes l'attak elle puisque ça les
arrange beaucoup sur elle ou je
reprendrai le mode son avocate qui a
parlé d'injustice je crois que vraiment
charles baron était toute sa vie
victime de la justice injustices du sort
un justice des hommes injustice de des
gens qui l'entouraient et je pense que
le mot c'est bien injustice fois je suis
d'accord également mais quelque chose
qui m'a pas les limites encore plus
encore plus choquée ya l'histoire mais
il ya aussi le fait que cette société
qui a commis ces injustices était à mon
avis parfaitement représentée par un
certain nombre de témoins et y compris
des membres de la cour dans leur
attitude dans leurs propos en partant du
psychiatre jusqu'à l'inspecteur de
police en retraite
l'avocat général etc il ya vraiment là
le résumé - des témoins
enfin je joue remettra en cause tout à
l'heure mais je préfère le faire oui au
bon moment d'accord bien il ya eu mort
d'homme à commencer par dire m simonetti
et je pense que c'était un rappel
nécessaire tellement on oublier que l'on
se trouvait en face d'une meurtrière et
que on voyait charline baron comme une
victime
je pense que les témoignages
correspondent les uns avec les autres et
nous brosse un tableau de cette femme
finalement que sérieuse en travail
excellente mère enfant traumatisé violé
deux fois et je pense que c'est toute la
notion et la tragédie de la femme violée
qui a honte en plus et qui n'ont
généralement pas cédé fin j'étais frappé
moi personnellement par l'agressivité
dont elle faisait preuve en général les
gens qui ont fait un long séjour en
prison des gens qui en bavent devant des
juridictions les cours d'assises en
particulier après un long séjour en
prison
on t'a pris à modérer leur impulsion au
moins devant nous voilà j'ai été très
frappé par l'agressivité dont elle a
fait preuve et vous disait madame raoulx
tout à l'heure que il n'y a pas beaucoup
de gens qui l'aiment mais croyez-vous
qu'elle aime beaucoup de gens oui si on
lui en donnait la possibilité est
certainement où il c'est ça le problème
c'est qu'apparemment personne ne lui en
donne la possibilité à part ma maman
treignes qui apparemment m l'aiment
vraiment sincèrement il lui dit c'est la
seule qui peut vous je crois tout de
même père s'est renfermée sur elle-même
et qu'elle est installée à l'intérieur
d'une coquille ou elle ne voit pas la
vie et les choses comme elle devrait les
voir objectivement je pense que sur ce
plan là il ya peut-être là une quelque
chose qu'il faudrait essayer de
d'élucider je crois justement qu'elle
voit les choses res et aubrey
objectivement ici pour ça que même les
personnes qu'ils aiment c'est pour ça
que qu'elles ne savent ou si pas pour ça
c'est pas parce que quelqu'un vous aime
que vous devez effectivement ne plus
rien dire et accepter leur amour est en
fait c'est ça qu'elle fait et je ne sens
pas une démarche ouverte vers cet amour
du prochain vous parlez vous voyez vous
pas ce que je veux dire c'est pour ça
que j'ai parlé qu'elle se renfermait un
peu je pense que c'est passé mon
sentiment elle se renferme tout de même
un peu laissé enfermer bon à tort aux
prises de résistance elle était un peu
rejetés par ses collègues du syndicat
qui n'ont pas créé un peu à ceux à ce
premier viol dit non ce n'est pas le
moment
bon a déchiré sa carte syndicats on n'a
pas soutenu à ce moment là mais tout le
monde savait chaque 6.2 qu'elle essaye
de faire quelque chose chaque fois elle
se trouve devant quelque chose qui qui
lui revient en retour mais contrairement
à ce qu'elle pensait elle fait le bien
les seuils mais à chaque fois elle prend
une gifle elle prend elle prend une
injustice de plus de 2 fois c'est avec
eux c'est ses enfants c'est chaque fois
c'est une injustice
alors évidemment ça c'est le vernont
disons à témoigner en disant justement
elle que nous ennuyait elle cherchait
constamment a parlé de deux crèches des
choses comme ça ils pensaient donc
c'était finalement en plus d'ennuis que
de satisfaction réelle qu'ils ont mettez
tout sans sa vie à cette cause devait
très déçu et c'est ce qui explique cette
attitude un récit qu'elle a envers
toutes les personnes
vous avez parlé du phénomène est
intéressant vie j'ai pas tellement aimer
l'autre je vous ai fait j'ai été
vraiment surpris par tout un tas de
problèmes qui sont posés le jugement
un jugement moraliste quand même assez
épouvantable sur le concubinage mai 68
et herat une façon de d'attaqué
l'incohérence de l'accusé avec alors là
je me suis vraiment une incompréhension
totale de comment fonctionne quelqu'un
que ce soit un homme ou une femme placée
face à des situations comme ça les
prétendus l'incohérence de l'accusé bon
là c'était une assistance vraiment
d'autre part que j'ai trouvé déplacé la
manière d'être choqués par son langage
alors que font dans le langage après on
a quand même eu des vertes et des pas
mûres
ça m'a vraiment
enfin profondément choqué que vous ayez
adopter ce comportement là qu'était le
comportement de l'avocat général je n'ai
pas apprécié non plus et en fait tout
s'est passé comme si vous aviez essayé
de l'enlever de la tête des jurés
ce que le fonds de la faire c'est à dire
que dans tout ça toute sa vie il a été
une victime qu'elle essayait de se
défendre comme victimes passives qu'elle
essayait de défendre mais qu'elle ait
pris des coups dans la gueule
vous avez essayé de nier ça à chaque
fois en démolissant tout ce qui de
démolir constamment cette évidence que
le procès ne serait pas un procès d'els
mais un procès du violeur des violeurs
et de la société et que c'est elle la
victime
je partage le point de vue de monsieur
robert sur l'avocat général qui a été
odieux cruel et d'ailleurs je me
réservais tout à l'heure la possibilité
de le démonter de dire quelques dégâts
ce sujet là mais vis-à-vis du président
non je pense qu'il a fait son rôle de
président c'est à dire qu'il a et il a
essayé d'être logique je crois quand
même plus voyez les choses parole avec
une optique un petit peu comment
dirais-je subjective si je peux dire on
a l'impression d'entendre vos propos que
vous êtes de excusez moi du terme qui
peut être vous choquer nous sommes là
pour parler librement un peu
révolutionnaire dans le sens noble du
terme je veux dire par là et que vous
vous heurtez que par ce biais n'est ce
pas vous vous vous heurtez aux
institutions charline et ce qu'elle
n'est pas jugée et accusé pascal parce
qu'elle a des comportements
révolutionnaire parce qu'elle essaye
d'organiser des crèches dans les usines
parce qu'elle ne se laisse pas faire et
que l'expriment est ce que c'est ça un
comportement évolutionnaire les propos
de monsieur sont peut être subjectif
mais je pense que en effet je crois de
toute manière qu'il faut laisser à
chacun son rôle aussi bien suivi
l'avocat général qu'à celui de la
défense
mais ce qui me choque surtout c'est
l'incompréhension c'est presque
l'inadaptation de cette femme vis-à-vis
de son milieu social enfin ce qui m'a
surtout choqué c'est les sons certains
témoins qui sont arrivées qui ont
témoigné et qui
cette femme et tout le monde l'a
ressenti était accablée par ces témoins
mais le problème était de savoir dans
quelle mesure où il est juste qu'elle
soit prise par rapport à ces gens disons
vers le témoignage du psychiatre m'a un
peu choqué en ce sens que ils
l'attaquent c'est d'orgueilleux je crois
et puis d'inhiber bon ça peut-être sont
des termes techniques et lui reprochait
d'avoir des préceptes moraux des choses
comme ça oui il faut pas important et ça
il ne faut pas oublier qu'il ya quand
même eu meurtre et je crois qu'on a
quand même tendance à l'oublier dans
cette affaire oui mais aussi un milieu
violent avec préméditation selon ce que
nous racontent les témoins alors qu'elle
n'a pas tué avec préméditation comme
elle l'a dit et ne savaient plus où elle
était c'était le cauchemar
on veut que ça arrête on tape dessus
pour que ça s'arrête
mais moi je pense qu'elle a eu tort de
donner rendez vous intimes devant le
numéro trois de ceux de réputation plus
que jusqu'au 13 elle aurait pu donner un
rendez-vous autres comme m'a dit que
général oui parce que c'était de
réputation bon sans problème
on donne rendez vous là c'est sait déjà
c'est une incitation je sais pas s'il a
vraiment qu'on se trouvait là sur place
à ce moment là je ne sais pas si bons
était consentante à ce moment là comme
le suggérait était consentante à quoi la
laque s'est produit parce que monsieur
suppose que elle s'est rendue à ce
rendez vous elle est bloquée inhibée ans
nous dit elle reste toujours refermer
sur elle-même
est ce que ce n'est pas par mesure de
honte de crainte de timidité qu'elle
finalement essaie de se faire le moins
voir possible elle choisit une heure
tardive la première fois pour monsieur
leroux je crois et elle choisit une
deuxième fois un endroit où
peut-être c'est elle qui s'y passe
certaines choses mais pour pas qu'on la
voit rencontré monsieur entraygues
moi j'avais noté tout de suite la
pression qu'elle m'a fait voyez
beaujolais noté et j'ai noté que c'était
une impression de filles simples j'ai
mis entre guillemets simple elle est
crédule si je puis dire d'une certaine
mesure elle très très dur sur le plan
d'humeur que justement je trouve qu'elle
a tout de même agi avec une grande
légèreté en donnant rendez-vous comme on
l'a dit dans son langage cet individu
cher l'antec dont elle connaissait les
quelque sorte de la réputation là ça
c'est un être candidat c'est ce que j'ai
dit on pourrait se poser la question si
vous voulez de l'attitude de l'accusé
est ce qu'elle est pas là pas une
attitude équivoque qui fait qu'elle a
quand même à faire à deux violes ce qui
n'est pas courant dans la vie de femme
qu'est ce qui se passait donc ça se
passe comme ça à vis à vis d'elle ou
alors est-ce qu'elle repoussait
tellement les hommes que finalement elle
suscité plus tôt l'euro finalement il a
il l'a remarqué plus qu'une autre ou je
ne sais pas elle repousse est banalement
les hommes puisque elle vivait
maritalement avec quelqu'un
maritalement mais oui comment son
premier viol mais donc ssl il avait un
comportement normal
et ben oui cette phase c'était tenait
qu'à un moment ou à un autre de sa vie
un moment ou à un autre de sa vie elle
n'est pas rencontré quelqu'un quand même
pour l'aider plus que ça à la sortir
vraiment de cette ornière où elle
s'organiser quand même de plus en plus
de s'en sortir mais en plus de ça vous
voyez vous ce premier concubin n'est ce
pas qu'il l'a laissé avec deux enfants
puisque j'ai noté qu'il n'avait pas
reconnu ses enfants départissant le
répétait qu on avait l'impression tout
de même qu'elle a dit ça d'une manière
mais il n'a même pas fait la proposition
éventuellement n'est ce pas dire que m
ça m'a choquée qu'elle a refusé de faire
reconnaître ses enfants et je pensais
que c'était vraiment parce qu'elle
repoussait dans le fond les hommes dans
tout ce qui pouvait lui apporter
même le nom pour ses enfants mais moi je
pense aussi que ça serait bien
elle a toujours été habitué à se
débrouiller à se bagarrer seul pourquoi
est-ce que du jour au lendemain parce
qu'elle a des enfants il faudrait
absolument un an mais surtout un mari
pour la défendre contre cette société
entendu mais pour elle je crois que la
démarche a été jusqu'à maintenant je me
suis débrouillé seul je vois pas
pourquoi que maintenant que j'ai les
enfants il faudra effectivement que je
me retrouve forcément à deux c'est ça me
paraît assez grave de juger quelqu'un
sur fond de juger de porter un jugement
sur lui à partir d'une confrontation
entre la manière dont elle vit et la
manière dont nous on vit et à plusieurs
reprises moi j'ai été vraiment frappé
que par exemple le concubinage soient
assimilés à des moeurs que le fait
d'être engagé
est engagée sur le plan militants à un
quelconque niveau ce soit un
comportement névrotique à partir du
moment où on décrète que tout ce que
fait l'autre s'il ne fait pas comme nous
c'est névrotique où c'est quelqu'un de
fermé etc
on commence à rentrer sur un jugement de
la personnalité alors qu'on a le droit
d'avoir une personnalité différente
c'est c'est déjà à justifier l'agression
de quelqu'un sur quelqu'un en disant que
non seulement c'est normal mais ça lui
fait du bien c'est pas faim ne faut pas
s'engager sur cette voie là quoi ensuite
les braises produit dans le sens de
monsieur robert contredire que la
cuisine parce qu'on ne répond pas à la
norme que la tossée se donne de
quelqu'un comme lui demande un
personnage qui ne répond pas du tout à
ce qu'on pourrait donner dans l'ensemble
je trouve je trouve que son comportement
s'explique assez bien la mesure où on
peut prendre comme point de départ le
viol de ses parents présents ce qui
s'est passé entre ses parents c'est là
que remonte le choc psychologique
elle a reçu enfants et à partir de ce
moment là il me semble qu'elle a
toujours été sur la défensive et c'est
pour ça que finalement toutes ces
initiatives parce que certains ont dit
qu'elles étaient fermés mais elle a pris
comme beaucoup d'initiatives et militer
et surtout dans le féminisme prendre
part
à des actions en 1968 c'est quand même
de prendre des initiatives à mon avis et
le fait que ça ne marche pas c'est vient
du fait que finalement elle n'a peut
être pas la vitalité la crédibilité
qu'auraient quelqu'un de sûr qui est sûr
de soi l'impression qu'elle est toujours
sur la défensive et finalement le
meurtre aussi c'est une défense à la
limite vous dit elle est ouverte parce
qu'elle a fait ceci et la festiva mais
ça ne marche jamais ce qu'elle fait et
ça marche jamais depuis l'origine
depuis depuis l'âge de 5 6 ans ça marche
plus alors est ce que pour autant
faut-il en conclure que tout ce qu'il
entreprendra sa négatives dans sa vie
quoi qu'elle fasse elle est arrivée à
être défaitiste d'ailleurs c'est pour ça
qu'elle dit à la fin nous vous ne me
croyez pas c'est inutile je pense que on
a parlé de beaucoup de son enfance ses
parents qui s'étaient mariés dans les
conditions un peu spécial on a parlé
beaucoup aussi du fait que était un peu
que c'est son sa mère ne venait pas
l'avoir parce que son père ne laissait
pas venir avant de parler de son enfance
on n'a pas parlé de ses enfants alors je
dois savoir quand même elle était
féministe elle était engagé
syndicalement elle était mais et ses
enfants qu'est ce qui devenait parce que
si elle a eu une enfance malheureuse je
pense qu' il faudrait qu'elle reporte un
peu sur ses enfants
les idées qu'elle agit des remplacements
et là elle adorait ses enfants ikks
n'est pas une accusée très sympathique à
l'avoir et avec l'attitude qu'elle a
raison dans son box d'accusés
je pense que c'est plutôt son histoire
disons qu'ils nous la rend
vraiment très sympathique sinon elle
n'est pas une accusée qui inspire la
sympathie je pense que vous avez tous pu
manifester votre opinion est que le
moment est venu de le passer au vote
conformément au voeu de m simonetti je
vais décomposer la question de
l'homicide volontaire c'est à dire que
nous devons répondre à quatre questions
je simplifie la formulation premièrement
charline baron est elle frappée blessé
charles entraygues
deuxièmement ces blessures ont elles
provoqué la mort de charles entraygues
troisièmement très importante
charline baron avait l'intention de tuer
charles entraygues bien pour que
l'accusé soit reconnu coupable
je vous rappelle que huit au moins
d'entre d'entre nous doivent répondre
oui aux questions concernant la
culpabilité
il suffit donc de cinq voix 5 bulletins
portant le mot non donc là soit
définitivement considérée comme
innocente
prenez un des bulletins posé devant vous
et inscrivez et inscrivez votre réponse
par oui ou non
[Musique]
deux reprises accusé rester debout
voici les réponses aux questions et
l'arrêt délibéré en commun aux deux
premières questions concernant la
culpabilité la réponse a été oui à la
majorité de huit voix au moins
la troisième question concernant
l'intention homicide la réponse a été
non la quatrième question concernant les
circonstances atténuantes la réponse a
été oui vu les réponses dont il vient
d'être donné lecture vu les articles 309
et 463 du code pénal vu les articles 366
7 134 et 749 et suivants du code de
procédure pénale la cour d'assises après
en avoir délibéré conformément à la loi
condamne le baron charles marie à la
peine de une année d'emprisonnement et
considérant qu'elle n'a jamais été
condamné antérieurement
dès qu'ils se rassurent si pendant cinq
années à l'exécution de ladite peine la
condamne au départ vers l'état texto
minimum la contrainte par corps
condamnez vous disposez de 5 jours
francs pour vous pouvoir en cassation
contre l'arrêt qui vient d'être rendue
passé ce délai votre pauvre âme ne sera
recevable bien d'emmener la condamner
l'audience est levée
[Musique]